es el fin a una relación de 47 años
reino unido y la unión europea-
definieron un histórico acuerdo
comercial y de cooperación post pre
decide el pacto prevé el libre
intercambio de bienes y servicios sin
aranceles ni cuotas aunque con más
restricciones que en la transición una
salida airosa para el reino unido que se
arriesgaba a enfrentar tarifas en luego
de tres décadas en el mercado único el
acuerdo también modifica las reglas en
un área clave la pesca con esta
normativa la unión europea acepta un
recorte del 25 por ciento de las cuotas
en aguas británicas durante cinco años y
medio estará garantizado el acceso
recíproco a las aguas pero tras ese
periodo las condiciones se definirán en
negociaciones anuales
jeffrey por primera vez desde 1973
seremos un estado costero independiente
con control total de nuestras aguas con
la participación del reino unido- de la
pesca aumentando sustancialmente de
aproximadamente la mitad actual a más de
cerca de dos tercios en cinco años y
medio
el texto contempla que londres y
bruselas mantengan un campo de juego
nivelado con los mismos estándares de
competencia y protección al medio
ambiente
desde el primero de enero de 2021
existirán controles aduaneros en las
fronteras y los ciudadanos no podrán
circular libremente instalarse y
trabajar o estudiar para estancias
superiores a 90 días se deberán
solicitar los visados correspondientes
también se acabará el reconocimiento
mutuo de las calificaciones
profesionales
este es un día difícil para algunos ya
nuestros amigos en reino unido- quiero
decirles despedirse es un dolor tan
dulce kings es sachs sweet
una despedida que tampoco será
definitiva a la cooperación esperada
entre las partes se agrega que el
acuerdo incluye periodos de transición y
cláusulas de revisión lo que vaticinan
nuevas negociaciones en el futuro